my buddy asked me to throw a bachelor
party and I was like man you don't want
me to do that I called her on the phone
she is six foot 250.
and her special skill is that she'll
come over to your house she'll get naked
and she'll toss you around for a little
while
[Laughter]
they're running at each other and my
buddy was mad and he screamed I want to
take you down
running at each other full speed and he
ran into her I'm gonna tell you
something he really did try to take her
down I'll tell you what he did not
all I can tell you is that when his
little body hit hers
she kind of absorbed him for a second
and he disappeared I was like where the
[__] did he go
and then she just shot him out across
the room boom and he slid on the floor
and one of my friends ran up to him and
went that just [__]
[Music]